hey it's Andy Cohen here at BuzzFeed I
can't wait to read your thirst tweets
[Music]
what's up with Andy Cohen's tennis
outfit and why is my Carter than it's
ever been
Jewish eye candy I don't wear that
tennis outfit again hey Andy I want to
suck your I want to sit on your face
suck my hole dry until I prolapses it
sounds like a medical condition Andy
Cohen needs to be what happens live in
my bus C is a bus e a mail
I want Andy Cohen to slam me harder than
Theresa slam that table while calling me
a prostitution [ __ ] keeping this one
that's a cute avatar Andy Cohen looks
like he got a thick and fat balls oh god
I can say with 100% certainty that I
would have a threesome with Andy Cohen
and mark Feuerstein don't act like you
wouldn't see that she picked you Jewish
guys I am so wet Andy I flood my
basement daddy
why won't Andy Cohen smother me in the
night with his left thigh I'd let Andy
Cohen bareback me but only if he kept
the suit on all right
deal with that that's your fetish I just
want Andy naked and on top of me how do
I make this happen ashtag Andy Cohen
hashtag babe I like really want to go on
a date with Andy Cohen well that's
g-rated deer at Andy Cohen I cordially
invite you to sit on my 9-inch you are
so [ __ ] sexy sounds painful did y'all
see Andy Cohen's tongue hot damn I bet
he eats good ass I did win a long tongue
contest in Miami
I love Andy Cohen he's like the coolest
dude I've seen on TV the best smile -
that's a tweet I could show my mom I
really want to marry Andy Cohen we'd go
to cool beaches and watch baseball and
take shots of whiskey and they'd never
break my heart Excel you put all the
romantic ones on the bottom okay maybe
the roast most dramatic one of all breed
me thank you for the invitation
I thought dudes were gonna be mean
tweets there's something quite different
titillated and I took someone's number
thanks BuzzFeed I'm Andy Cohen you blew
my mind
[Music]